now it is time for puppy pig skin picks
sponsored by subaru of las vegas and we
have john from the animal foundation
with us today
with zoe good morning to you john good
morning alex tell us about beautiful zoe
zoe is eight years old she's 70 pounds
she came to us as a stray she's been
there for
about over a month now and she's a
really
gentle dog really great leash skills
very easy on the leash
she's a great person very well mannered
does she do well with other dogs and
kids
yes as far as we know she came in as a
stray so we don't have a big background
on her
but as far as we know from shelter she's
very good with other dogs she's very
sweet you have something very exciting
coming up your big fundraiser the best
of show
we do it's best in show and it's been
rescheduled this year to sunday november
15th
um people can go online if they're
familiar with it it's what we can
we mimic the westminster dog show with
shelter dogs
so there's different categories of dogs
so they can go up the public can go
online
and sign up for 20 fee and it's a live
stream event so it's totally virtual
this year
which is a little different than our
previous years perfect
and that's coming up in november yes and
all proceeds benefit the foundation
absolutely it's our biggest fundraiser
of the year it's really important
wonderful okay so look at zoe she is
such a good little girl
we're going to ask zoe though to get up
and pick a team it's the chiefs and the
broncos this week
zoe do you want to get one of your
treats oh
and it's the broncos thank you john
thank you alex how cute is zoey
all right if you'd like to adopt her
call the animal foundation the number
is 955-5901
zoe is so well behaved john she knows
her uh commands
she lays and sits with view of a tree
but the question is does she know her
football
well we'll see